a new state of play is on the way and
nintendo online subscribers are getting
some new games
sony has announced a new playstation
state of play airing next week promising
new announcements including games for
the playstation vr2 this event which is
set to run for about roughly 30 minutes
will take place on thursday june 2nd at
3 p.m pacific time 6 p.m eastern and we
will be streaming it right here on the
gamespot youtube channel the
announcement did not include many
details on what the presentation will
include but an accompanying playstation
blog post promised quote exciting
reveals from our third party partners
plus a sneak peek at several games in
development for playstation vr2 that
could mean we won't see any of sony's
non-vr first party lineup reporter jeff
grubb speculated that this could be
where we see street fighter 6 debut this
event is coming amid various other not
e3 events and more than a week before
the competing xbox and bethesda showcase
there is no traditional e3 this year but
we are seeing several publishers and
platform holders announce events to take
place in june regardless and you'll want
to tune in to gamespot for coverage of
all the shows whether it's the summer
game fest the xbox and bethesda showcase
and more sony has consistently said that
its big 2022 game god of war ragnarok is
still on target to launch this year that
makes the potential absence of first
party games notable but sony could be
planning a separate event to show off
its own games in other sony news the
company announced two new tv shows
during an earnings presentation q a the
shows include a god of war tv series
coming to amazon and a horizon series
that's being made for netflix meanwhile
deadline reports that gran turismo is
being made into a movie instead of a tv
show interestingly in may 2021 a sony
spokesperson confirmed that a god of war
tv series was not happening but plans
can always change as they have now in
nintendo news a switch demo for the
mario striker's battle league online
mode will go live from june 3rd until
june 5th anyone with nintendo switch
online membership can access the demo
and the tutorial section of the game is
live now for expansion pass members if
you're looking to see how you'll fare
against human opponents in online play
you can hop on during the times i've
listed on screen
and while we're on the subject of things
that nintendo switch online subscribers
can do there is a new update that adds
three new games to its nes and super nes
libraries those include the early nes
pinball game simply titled pinball the
beat'em up rival turf and the mascot
platformer congo's caper as always you
don't need to download these games
individually instead they're packaged
into updates for the individual nes and
super nes apps which house each of the
games in the collection on nintendo
switch switch owners who opt for the
pricier expansion pass also get a
collection of genesis and n64 games
though no new games were added to those
collections in this update it's a long
weekend here in america so hit the
comment section and let me know what
you're getting into or what you're
playing and i'll see you next week